oh
[Musique]
bon
bienvenue à bord de la fille only avec
ses 15 mètres de long 4 mètres de large
il accueille une salle de concert et son
mât de 12 mètres certes d'agrès aux
acrobates en transformant en bateau
spectacle on a construit à avoir un
ascenseur à piano on fait un spectacle
qui s'appelle bateau piano trapèze avec
deux pianistes de trapézistes
l'attestation mesure et on a dû prendre
en compte effectivement on sait pas pris
sur le bateau en fait c'est vraiment au
fond de cale pour pâques et d'efforts
pour dans le mauvais sens de la coque en
naviguant au gré des répétitions et des
dates de concerts le chaland est devenue
une résidence d'artistes et bien plus
encore houssen un lieu de résidence
un lieu de concert frais oui pour le
fret aussi donc du coup vraiment une
sorte de caravane comme ça qu'il peut
emmenez plein de choses plein de
spectacles de poésie
[Musique]
on a un peu conçu le le gréement du
bateau donc tous les goûts tous les
cordages et les espars qui servent à
tenir la voile on les a renforcés avec
d'autres cordages pour pouvoir
accueillir de trapèze parce que hannah
quand elle quand elle fait des
suspensions un peut atteindre 300 kg
pour les acrobates les haubans offre une
piste aux étoiles entre loire et ciel le
fait que ça bouge tout le temps jusque
là par exemple le trapèze
il va s'il gauche et à droite le sol
bouge parce que c'est de l'eau
il ya tout qui bouge du coup c'est
complètement différente d'habitude y'a
rien qui ait vraiment stable et les deux
buts là qui tiennent la vergue ils
peuvent pas être super tendu tout est
très souple
je fais ça il ya tout ce qui bouge
ol et les transformations de la fille
own riz c'est l'histoire de sa vie
attaquer la construction et j'avais 19
ans donc du coup j'ai pas mal grandi
avec ce bateau et puis et puis je le
modifie au fur et à mesure de des années
de l'expérience de
des envies de deux programmes et de
navigation
voilà c'est un bateau roman évolutif le
chaland de loire ce sera adapté à toutes
les époques et toutes les utilisations
du fleuve royal